guardzilla well a sky Tolton as we all
heard there is a trailer for the new
godzilla movie coming out this is the
first trailer we've had other than the
Comic Con footage and everyone would
apeshit at Comic Con for the Comic Con
footage so we were all like all right
trailers coming out soon not too soon
because the trailer just came out
ultimately doesn't really show much
which I completely expected because God
people like holding Godzilla close to
the chest when I was watching this
trailer I was like I'm not gonna see
Godzilla at all for the most part you
see him a little bit not too much though
if you didn't know is it Godzilla
trailer you wouldn't think it was a
Godzilla trailer you think it was act of
valor too we're all hanging out with
Navy SEALs they're getting their lecture
and like alright we're gonna do a halo
jump that's high altitude low open for
those of you who have not played Metal
Gear Solid 3 if I did not have complete
faith in your ability to succeed it
looks really cool this trailer has a
really eerie feeling to it I've always
said the first trailer doesn't show you
much about the movie it's all about tone
and that's what this is this is a teaser
trailer that shows you the tone of the
movie granted usually trailers like this
or the trailers that come out a year
before the movie comes out and the
release of Godzilla is just a few months
away but point is that's the point of
this trailer they're parachuting you're
like alright they're falling to hell
tell me that's not what that is sorry
for my sins
I like the part in the trailer were it
seen - one of the Navy SEALs eyes he was
looking around it's really intense and
you see it you see this spines
and after all that you see some
compelling imagery [ __ ] getting torn in
half Bryan Cranston
yes Bryan Cranston okay well I'll watch
the movie I was on the fence with a big
lizard tearing [ __ ] through his city but
you bring it Heisenberg and alright I'm
there and other things like our good
friend Merv and star trek into darkness
this movie does what I like when I'm
watching a monster movie or playing a
game where something's supposed to be
enormous its surroundings work with it
all the debris falling off its arms
falling really slowly you're like that
looks huge just a teaser trailer I feel
like it's a teaser trailer that's a
little late to the party but this
movie's been so shrouded in secrecy
doesn't surprise me at all that this is
the trailer we're getting a few months
before the movie comes out I like the
tone of the movie I like the visuals of
the movie it looks like Godzilla it's
gonna tear [ __ ] through city and it's
all gonna look really devastating I will
say this is a smart way to go about it
before we had Matthew Broderick and
scientists and boring let's do the exact
opposite bring in the military might we
have ourselves an exciting movie it
works for aliens I think this could work
for Godzilla a few Navy SEALs doing a
covert off to take out a big lizard
that's a [ __ ] Tilian times bigger than
any dinosaur you gotta think about that
belt if a SEAL team can take out
Godzilla that's pretty much saying
Godzilla bin Laden same thing voice of
Godzilla have you seen the trailer and
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]